will we get to visit numenor when will
sauron show up and what a half foot
amazon's a ring of power features new
characters and uncharted lands here's
what you need to know
the upcoming series wasn't called the
lord of the rings the rings of power in
august of 2021 the studio hadn't
announced an official title yet and fans
commonly referred to the project as
amazon's lord of the rings series or
something along those lines and yet even
without a title the show went ahead and
announced the premiere of its first
episode which would air more than a year
in the future on august 2nd of 2021
amazon published a press release that
included a gorgeous first series image
and the announcement that episode 1
would drop on september 2nd of 2022 well
fans have had to literally wait for
years at this point the good news is
that they won't have to wait for much
longer
the lord of the rings the rings of power
had little to no visual promotional
elements for the first four years of its
existence but once 2022 kicked off we
got a sudden flood of promotional videos
the first of these is an epic title
reveal declaring that the show would be
called lord of the rings the rings of
power then amazon went and upped the
ante by releasing a full 60 second
trailer during the super bowl the
trailer didn't reveal too much detailed
information but it did finally give us a
solid glimpse of the world that amazon
is building to house this middle-earth
stories from sweeping panoramas to cgi
monsters to a slew of characters the
trailer created an instant buzz and a
variety of different levels of feedback
it was so heavily viewed that it broke
the first day trailer record getting 257
million views worldwide in just 24 hours
on july 8th another 60-second teaser
officially dropped ending with an
announcement that another teaser would
be arriving on the 14th of that same
month when that day arrived fans
refreshed their browsers with baited
breath and were rewarded at last with a
full two and a half minute trailer that
went deep into the details the trailer
focuses on the passage of time elves
discuss past glory and failures men
speak of moving forward and leaving the
past behind dwarves were in their prime
drawing rings of power talk of a new era
to come the trailer also puts the show's
incredible production quality on full
display scene after scene was shown
shifting from jaw-dropping panoramas to
live these civilizations orgs flash on
the screen for a moment elrond and
galadriel verbally spar over their
tragic past experiences the high elven
king gilgalad utters foreboding words
about an impending evil
after months of virtually nothing to
gauge how the show was going to feel the
second trailer effectively functioned as
a full-blown reveal of how epic the
rings of power experience could be
it will be the end not just of our
people
but all
peoples
with so much money and manpower going
into the series what story are they
going to tell well fans are used to the
stories of the hobbits and the lord of
the rings this time amazon's narrative
will be going much further afield and
further back in time too the show will
cover events that take place in the
second age of tolkien's world this is a
roughly 3
500 year long era that comes before the
3000 year long third age which ends with
the events of the hobbits and lord of
the rings if 3 500 years feels like a
very long span of time that's because
well it is in fact show runners jd payne
and patrick mckay have already clarified
that the biggest deviation from the
texts is a simple fact that they've
condensed all of the events of the
second age into a single point in time
according to pain we talked with the
tolkien estates if you are true to the
exact letter of the law you are going to
be telling a story in which your human
characters are dying off every season
because you're jumping 200 years in time
and then you're not meeting really big
important canon characters until season
four along with this major adjustment to
the pace of the narrative the
showrunners have explained that they
only have the rights to the lord of the
rings trilogy and the hobbit however
this gives them critical access to the
appendices of the return of the king
which includes a brief outline of events
in the second age working from this they
will try to bring together a coherent
condensed and compelling second age
narrative
one of the biggest concerns of any
on-screen fantasy or sci-fi adaptation
is how the show will utilize cgi even
within the hollowed world of middle
earth overuse of computer graphics has
already wreaked havoc on the hobbit
trilogy
fortunately rings of power addressed
this very real concern from the get-go
when the show's title reveal video was
released it featured an impressive title
drop later a behind the scenes video was
released showing everything from the
mould to fog machines and even the
pouring of real bonafide molten metal it
was a great way to showcase a series
commitment to practical effects
since that time the cast and showrunners
have relentlessly reinforced the idea
that rings of power isn't doing the bulk
of its filming in front of a green
screen in the same spirit as peter
jackson's venerated two decade old lord
of the rings trilogy
most shows need to approach production
one season at a time not so with rings
of power
this is a series that has a five season
story arc already fully planned from
beginning to end according to showrunner
jd payne we even know what to have a
final shot of the last episode is going
to be
this was a big story with a clear
beginning middle and end there are
things in the first season that don't
pay off until season 5. meanwhile the
eyebrow raising budget of the rings of
power production has steadily drawn
comments and criticism from the
beginning in an interview with empire jd
payne offered a rebuttal to concerns
about the rings of power budget and it
has to do with treating the rings of
power experience not as a show but as a
movie the show runner explained
we think it's important to keep the
budget in context really this season is
an eight hour movie this is the length
of three marvel films done on the
schedule of two for the budget of one
look at it in the context of what's
actually being produced and you could
say that it's a bargain
everyone loves siens the tree folk are a
fan favorite element of the lord of the
rings story and while they're certainly
important in the third age the events we
see in the lord of the rings really
amount to little more than the last
hurrah for the group in fact the most
important part of tree beard in a
species story happens during the second
age which is when the rings of power is
set from the get-go this prompted a
crucial question will the ends be in the
show it's an inquiry that was officially
answered in early july when a rings of
power teaser showed the tree folk for
the first time the quick and subtle
reveal all but confirms that ends will
be in the show but ben and mary would be
pleased
just talking mary the tree is talking
tree
i am no tree
the villain of the rings of power has
been set in stone from the get-go let's
not beat around the bush here it's
sauron tolkien made that clear in the
source material the second age is a time
when sauron rises and takes the place of
his fallen master the original dark lord
morgoth as forest has been revealed the
show hasn't deviated from this line of
reasoning in fact the initial synopsis
of the rings of power which was leaked
well before its premiere states that
hope hung by the finest of threads and
the greatest villain that ever flowed
from tolkien's pen threatened to cover
all the world in darkness while it isn't
explicitly stated it takes all of two
seconds to connect the darts it's safe
to assume that the greatest villain that
ever flowed from tolkien's pen is the
dark lord sauron and yet for all the
clarity the villain for the first season
of the show remains cloaked in mystery
early on a leak from the fansite one
ring.net clarified that sauron will not
be revealed in season one if true that
means our heroes are going to be facing
some other villains for a while we've
already seen trolls and orcs in the
promotional material and the saruman
once said do you know how the orcs first
came into being
they were elves once
the rings of power has its workers out
for itself when it comes to filling its
iteration of middle-earth with
compelling relatable characters why
because tolkien never wrote much about
this period of his world's history
instead he focused on outline level
material much of which the showrunners
and writers have had to connect and fill
in to create enough substance for a
50-hour story this could be the
beginning of a new era part of that
process has been inventing new
characters
this is an absolute necessity since
there are very few names in the source
material but it's also a task that is
fraught with peril inventing characters
out of whole cloth and expecting them to
stand toe to toe with the deep
thoughtful characters created by the
original author is a tall order it
remains to be seen if amazon's new
personalities will be able to hold their
own in middle earth
one exciting prospect of the rings of
power is the opportunity to see new
areas of middle earth that have not been
seen on the silver screen the bitter
cold northern terrain called the forward
waif was already showcased in the super
bowl trailer for one we're also going to
head to the left of the map across the
gigantic sundering seas that separate
middle earth from the blessed realm away
in the west where frodo and bilbo sail
to at the end of the return of the king
in the middle of this ocean lies the
island nation of numenor this is where
aragorn's ancestors live and it's a
really important area that is often
mentioned in the lord of the rings
however by that time the island is long
gone thanks to events that transpire you
guessed it during the rings of power
story the chance to see numenor in its
heyday and meet many of the famous
characters that dwell on its shores is
an exciting prospect
hobbits have no place in the larger
stories of middle earth before the third
age at least that's what tolkien wrote
one area where the rings of power
narrative seems to deviate from the
source material though is with the
subject of halfling history the show has
been careful to one of the fact that
third age hobbits really do live
entirely outside of the story however
they've taken a leap by choosing to
incorporate half foot into their own
second age narrative here are half foots
they're basically proto-hobbits the
prologue to the fellowship of the ring
states that before the crossing of the
misty mountains the hobbits had already
become divided into three somewhat
different breeds hartfords stewards and
fallow heights now this is still
referencing very late hobbit history
much later than the time of rings of
power nevertheless the show has gone
ahead and incorporated a group of
halflings which they're calling half
foot into the story
if you're picturing overweight
comfortable hobbits living in
well-tended holes in the shire you're
wrong the half foots are nomadic they're
survivors and they aren't anywhere near
their descendants comfortable chunk of
idyllic rural countryside while a lot of
details remain to be seen it would be
fascinating to see how the show tries to
work a group of halflings into a story
where tolkien himself clearly never
intended to have them involved
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite upcoming tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one